foreign
[Music]
today we're going to talk about what's
new in Cloud native CI CD
I'm David Jacobs and I'm a product
manager here at Google and I'm here with
Edward Thiel who's a software engineer
also at Google
we're going to start by talking about
the importance of CI CD in a modern
context as well as challenges that you
may face as you modernize your software
supply chain
we'll then talk about how software
delivery Shield which is Google Cloud's
secure software supply chain solution
can help in some of these areas
we'll cap things off with a demo to show
you how all of this comes together and
talk about potential next steps
it almost goes without saying but
continuous integration and continuous
delivery or CI CD are integral to Modern
software development
by continuously testing integrating and
deploying changes we can enable our
teams to move faster and with confidence
that we're meeting our customers needs
and expectations
in fact it's hard to imagine some of the
most successful companies and
Technologies operating today without
some form of testing and automation now
of course there isn't a
one-size-fits-all approach to devops or
CI CD
every organization is different and
there are several challenges that you
may face as you modernize
One Challenge you may face is how to
balance speed scale and security
these are all important goals to design
against but they're all related to each
other and they can't be optimized in
isolation in fact these goals may be in
tension with each other
you may design a system that's
completely scalable for example but it
may cost you in terms of velocity or you
may have a team that ships quickly but
doesn't take the time to secure its
software
while the exact balance is something
only you can decide there are a few best
practices that let you make the
trade-offs easier to manage
first let's talk about speed
here you're aiming to move faster as a
team and organization to meet Market
needs but in a way that's safe and it
won't cause problems down the road how
can you attain this speed well before
you try to move faster it's best to
Define exactly what you're measuring in
the first place there are many ways you
could measure velocity and the sheer
number of choices can be overwhelming
the good news is you can stand on the
shoulders of giants as you do this
in particular I'd encourage you to look
at research from devops research and
assessment or Dora to learn which key
metrics are associated with top
performers
once you've defined success try to
promote smaller more frequent changes in
order to stay Nimble by doing this you
can mitigate the risks and slowdowns
that are associated with larger changes
and finally it may in some cases be
worth considering managed services to
maximize the speed of your team
managed Services May reduce the burden
of infrastructure management and
security for your team and instead let
you focus on your differentiated value
and goals
next let's talk about scale a lot can be
said about scale but a key thing that I
want to mention today is that scale
doesn't have to be daunting
it's okay to start small with the CI CD
pipeline that works for one or two
projects and work your way up from there
if you hyper optimize for scale too
early in a project you may pose an
unnecessary risk to your team's velocity
at a point in time where the velocity is
an important factor at the same time
there are principles you can apply early
on that pay real dividends without too
much cost for example ensuring that
configuration is stored as code may be
slightly more effort up front but it
will likely mean that you don't need to
rewrite any pipelines when you achieve
greater scales related to this it's
important to choose tools and technology
that evolve in a similar fashion as your
needs grow in complexity
finally let's touch on security
now security is a big topic but I do
want to cover a couple of best practices
that are particularly relevant for CI CD
first and foremost I'd encourage you to
bake security into your process and to
do so early you may want to consider
potential bottlenecks and whether you
can ease these by shifting left on
security this may mean that Security
reviews happen early or even the
developers are thinking about security
as they code and as they do code review
Additionally you may decide it's
important to keep a human in the loop
for code changes or releases that meet a
certain risk threshold
tooling like manual approvals and
promotion can help out here you also
want to plan for workload observability
or knowing what code is running where
one last Point here is that salsa is a
standard specifically concerning the
software supply chain
not only does it describe the security
you can achieve in your cicd pipelines
but it gives you an incremental path to
get there
so how can Google help you on your
modernization journey
you may have heard earlier in the
conference about software delivery
Shield Google's secure software supply
chain solution
software delivery Shield covers many
areas and I want to talk a little bit
about how it helps with CI CD the first
service I want to talk about is cloud
build
Cloud build is a platform for continuous
integration and developer automation
that means that not only can you build
and test with Cloud build but you can
automate other tasks from source code as
well it's fully managed so you can focus
on your core competencies instead of
scaling build infrastructure Cloud build
has invested heavily in features that
help you modernize your CI pipelines
recent examples include salsa level 3
support private network connectivity and
Native Integrations with major source
code providers
Cloud build also lets you create a
pipeline with the simple build script
like the one you see on the right and as
your needs evolve and become more
complex Cloud build can handle that too
next artifact registry is a universal
management layer for images build
artifacts and application dependencies
not only does it let you store these
artifacts but it does so with high
availability artifact registry supports
a variety of languages and Native
artifact protocols you can also scan
these images and artifacts for
vulnerabilities
finally Cloud deploy is Google Cloud's
solution for continuous delivery
it supports deployment to multiple
runtimes including gke and Cloud run
like Cloud build Cloud deploy is fully
managed and takes the toil out of
managing CI CD infrastructure with Cloud
deploy you can manage releases
declaratively as code you can promote
releases to various environments and you
have tight control over approvals and
rollbacks you can also use cloud deploy
to verify that releases were successful
after the fact
so how does all of this come together
to answer this question I'm going to
turn it over to Edward who will show us
how to create a secure CI CD pipeline
for cloud run using Cloud build artifact
registry and Cloud deploy
hi everyone today we're going to walk
through how we set up a fast reliable
and secure CI CD pipeline using
components from software delivery Shield
we will use cloud build for a continuous
integration solution which will create
images in artifact registry these will
be deployed by Cloud deploy our
continuous delivery solution into Cloud
run
zooming in a bit we have Cloud build
connected to a private GitHub repository
and configured to lint build and test
our application on every merge domain
then it will package up the application
using Docker upload it to artifact
registry and create a release for
in-cloud deploy from there Cloud deploy
will automatically deploy the
application in the stating environment
and then run post-apoint verification
jobs which will ensure that our
applications behaving as we expect in a
real production-like environment
from there we can choose to promote a
successful release to production to
ensure production stability we've
configured Cloud deploy to require
approvals of the deployment by user with
the appropriate permissions before
allowing it to continue once approved
the application will be deployed to the
production Cloud run service where
another verification job is triggered to
ensure everything is working as we
expect here as well
now let's take a deeper look at our CI
CD configuration our application uses
configures code so doing that is as
simple as checking out our GitHub
repository
let's take a look at the cloud build
configuration first which will be
triggered automatically whenever code is
merged to me
here you can see that we have three
steps configured first we use Maven to
lint build and test our application
then we use Docker to build our
application container that will be
deployed to Cloud run and also to build
our verification container which is a
separate container that is used to
validate the deployment
finally we create a cloud deploy release
using images that we've just created and
uploaded to artifact registry
also note the images field below which
ensures that build provenance and the
appropriate attestations required by
binary authorizations are attached to
the images automatically
now let's take a look at our Cloud
deploy configuration
here you can see that we have a simple
two-stage pipeline deploying to staging
and production targets you'll notice
that both stages have a verification job
enabled and the production stage uses
its own scaffold profile in order to
account for differences in configuration
between staging and production let's
look at the targets themselves
you'll see that they point to two
different projects and have differing
service accounts configured both for
production and staging and also for the
different activities that occur as part
of deployment this makes it possible to
follow the principle of least privilege
where each action only has permissions
that it needs in order to run now let's
take a look at the scaffold
configuration
thank you
you can see a very simple setup that
indicates that this configuration is for
a cloud run Target with the service
definition in service.yaml by default
and in service Dash prod when the
production profile is active
both profile share of verification image
which verifies the most recently
deployed service we also build this
image as part of our Shri process
let's quickly look at the staging
service yaml which shows a simple Cloud
run config pointing to the image along
with some scale configurations
appropriate for our staging Target
now looking at production we see that it
has a different scale configuration but
also it enables binary authorization
which ensures that the application that
was being deployed was built by Cloud
build
and now let's take a quick look at our
verification job
this is a simple script configured to
send 50 requests to the application we
just deployed and verify that it meets
some average latency threshold note that
it does so using the credentials
configured earlier in the cloud
deployaml as the service is not open to
the general internet
now let's see how we can make a change
to the application and get it deployed
to production
here you see a simple hello world
application making a small change to the
text that is returned
note that when we did that we also
introduced a small performance
regression that is very likely to make
it past our CI test infrastructure but
it's likely to be impactful to our users
to deploy this change we simply commit
the change and push it to our Repository
and that's it
after merging the change domain the
build was created automatically and is
currently running in the interest of
time we'll fast forward builds and roll
up throughout this video
now the job was completed successfully
and here you can see it built the
application using Maven package and
uploaded the images and then created a
cloud deploy release
now we will see Cloud deploy pick up the
new release and deploy it to the first
Target in this case staging
you know however that the rollout to
staging fails to see why we can click
view rollout from the drop down
here we see while the deployment of the
runtime was successful the verification
job failed to understand why we go to
the logs for that event
and we can see that our performance
regression is the cause
we will fix that regression but in the
meantime we'll roll back the change to
staging in order to make the target
healthy
back in our editor we remove the code
that caused performance issue and leave
the desired change intact as before we
simply commit the change to main to
trigger the flow that will eventually
deploy the code to staging
and now we see the rollout start
and this time it's successful
just to be sure we can check the rollout
details
and see that both the deployment and
verification jobs are successful this
time
with everything working now we need to
promote this release to production
recall from the configuration that
production requires an approval to allow
for manual inspection of the release by
a user with the appropriate permissions
so now we'll go into the approval page
and look at the release being suggested
here we can look at the details of the
release including the images that are
associated with the release being
proposed
to inspect the image we can look at it
further in artifact registry
there we can see the results of the
vulnerability scan that was performed
automatically on upload and make an
informed choice about deploying that
image
we can also inspect the build provenance
to understand how that image was created
with that information in hand we decide
to approve the deployment
now we can see our approved rollout
deploying to production
first the deployment job passes followed
by the verification job
we have now successfully completed
making our change from commit all the
way through production deployment
we've now shown a simple pipeline that
allows you to iterate quickly without
compromising on security some ways we've
helped keep our pipeline secure is by
having Cloud build automatically provide
build provenance information using
artifact Registries built-in
vulnerability scanning depending on
cloud deploy to provide process control
to the delivery leveraging Cloud runs
integration with binary authorization
and though it wasn't stated explicitly
all interactions between these systems
were controlled via IAM policies going
forward one possible Next Step would be
to scale this configuration by
leveraging terraform support
thank you everyone and back to you David
thanks Edward
I want to close with a few pointers
first if you'd like to get started with
any of the products we talked about
today I'd encourage you to check out
some great quick starts available at
cloud.google.com
if you'd like to dive deeper into
securing your software supply chain we
have you covered there too
we've built up a rich set of resources
describing industry best practices and
standards including salsa
and finally there's plenty more to learn
here at next in particular we have
sessions that cover Security in more
detail as well as developer productivity
and how to build modern but simple
applications
whether you're at the beginning of your
modernization journey or are well
underway I hope you'll consider what we
talked about today you may even consider
new ways of tackling the challenges we
described
Edward and I would like to thank you for
joining today and we hope you enjoy the
rest of next 22.
[Music]